during that time
when lucky you know there's a costello
himself banned you know
meyer they're sitting there and you know
uh rothstein's kind of giving them a
you know formula here's how you do it
here's how you make your money and don't
let the two more in order to do that
they had to kill
joe the boss they had to kill salvatore
marazzano
so the first one they took out was joe
the boss bustery in coney island
one jew and three italians bugsy siegel
together with three italians
went did the hit before joe the boss
masalia could eat that pasta bazoola
bianca he was
they ruined his appetite they killed him
yeah then
they had to take care of salvatore
marinzano in that particular case lucky
luciano
hey that's a good story he goes to meyer
lansky and he says to admire give me
four year guys
give me four jews because salvatore
maranzano will never recognize four jews
coming in
dressed as irs agents all right
so meyer lansky's using four four jewels
um bugsy i think one of the guys from
dutch schultz's outfit i always said
louis rush
from downtown and the fourth guy
was um sam uh
red levine all right that was meyer
lansky's
favorite shooter now my sam
red levine with a strong reputation he
was a bit of a religious jew
yeah he wore kippah all right eight
kosher
and used to tell meyer lansky don't give
me an assignment on shabbat
unless it's absolutely necessary he
wouldn't kill anybody on saturday
unless that had to be taken care of so
after they killed those two guys emerges
1930-31 the the commission and the new
crime
the five families and so forth and so
forth that's where lucky luciano
really gets the respect of everybody
to bring the five so because in fact it
was joe the boss masariyah
that kidnapped salvatore
lacania
it takes him to his warehouses and
threatens him that if you don't come
with me
i'm gonna kill you in lucky luciano it
was named salvatore lacani at the time
is the original name of lucky luciano
says
no i'm not going with you they sliced
them up left them for dead
and that's how we got the name lucky he
was lucky to survive
that's when he went to myron to benny
the bugsy
and says guys god bless you next we'll
never
we'll never we'll never succeed
as long as we're under the limitations
of the repression
of these old xenophobic dinosaurs
got to get rid of them so i got rid of
them and that's
where the jews and the italians
had a good understanding and excellent
understanding
that we're going to cooperate and
cooperation means more money
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye